et des comédiens professionnels fait le
théâtre cet été pour la troisième année
la compagnie les tréteaux de france
revient à lille de loisirs pour une
semaine de partage des ateliers des
saynètes des petites pièces de théâtre
et des vrais représentation donc qu'ils
sont qui sont assurés par des comédiens
professionnels et qui là sont aussi
gratuite donc
idem ces inscriptions obligatoires en
revanche sur le site mais c'est vraiment
un projet qui est super pendant dix
jours fin août le site propose aussi des
afterworks à chaque jeudi au restaurant
les alizés musique et jeux sont annoncés
une exposition la découverte des métiers
de la radio complètent toute cette
programmation à la commanderie l'art se
mêle à la science jusqu'au 31 juillet
les jeunes de 6 à 17 ans découvre à
travers différence d'âge la danse et les
arts visuels
on est quatre missions installés ici et
l'idée c'est qu'on propose aussi au
public de traverser tous les genres
qu'on défend à la commanderie
les enfants sont vraiment en immersion
et c'est ce qui nous intéresse aussi
dans ce projet de c'est les vacances
c'est que les enfants soient en
immersion toute la journée avec
l'artiste avec l'intervenant est avec
ses petits copains d'ateliers du côté du
musée de la ville les expositions sont
prolongées et en ces temps compliqués
les équipes rivalisent d'imagination
pour faire découvrir le patrimoine saint
quentinois et également des visites à
vélo qui sont des formules qui sont très
chouette l'été et faut dire que ça
quentin en yvelines offre une quantité
de sentiers de chemin qu'on peut
utiliser un vélo et qui permettent
vraiment de re découvrir ce territoire
autrement et souvent les gens sont
vraiment surpris de ce dont on peut
parcourir l'ensemble du territoire du
land art à la balade connecter de
nombreux autres activités sont proposées
l'été sera culturel à saint quentin en
yvelines